part of MLB network's live World Series
coverage beginning today at 3:00 p.m.
Eastern or noon at Dodger Stadium MLB
tonight will air at 6:00 p.m. Eastern
time and right after tonight's game six
and then if necessary tomorrow's game
seven good to see you sure it's great to
see you man thanks for having me you bet
I don't know if I can take you seriously
well maybe why didn't I dress up if you
don't got the memo I would have dressed
up do you watch yeah this is it I'm
thought well Larry David I love it
remember remember the a-team oh yeah I'd
say like if you lost the mustache cut
your hair a little bit with the jacket
well basically when a plan comes
together
take the whiff I take off the wig and
the moustache I I might be mistaken for
georgeanna part is that was he ba
Baracus
is that who you was no he was so let's
let's use that as a segue the plan
coming together for the Astros which is
let these kids rake and tax that Dodger
bullpen if they could get into it and
man they were able to do that against
Clayton Kershaw unbelievable well what
was unbelievable about Game five was if
you go up for nothing a clean Kershaw I
marked the rosin I were watching it
we're like let's just go back to the
hotel game was over and all of a sudden
you know Jerry L ends up hitting that
three-run bomb they tie it at four and
then when Bellinger came and made it 74
you thought okay Clayton Kershaw can't
blow a four run in a three-run lead that
lineup just keeps coming at you for the
Astros and that's it you make a mistake
on them and they're making you pay this
series say do you think the balls juiced
and do I think the ball is juiced uh
well I mean there's a lob see the most
homeruns ever this year it seems like
everyone's hitting 20 to 25 but in this
world series you're hearing Tom Verducci
say that yeah it's a little slick right
so the slider the sliders are basically
been removed from everybody's repertoire
right what I'm saying right you but do
you believe I mean the only reason I
kind of believe it is because a bunch of
guys have said it you know Brent Strom
the pitching coach for the Astros came
out and said it Verlander talked about
it I mean a lot of guys I think you
Darvish Yu Darvish was talking about so
the fact that a lot of people are saying
that they mean maybe there's some
validity to it
but I guess it's both teams they both
have to say they're both throwing the
same ball
I mean do you like a game did you like a
game like Game five or dude is that just
a lot of it to off the rails for you I
loved it especially being there in
Houston and that place was rocking it is
literally literally rocket I mean shaken
when you know the back and forth all
night long I like it you're not it not
all the time do you see a 13 to 12 game
especially in the World Series it even
during the regular season but the
magnitude of the moment and the the
energy in that place I thought it was
great yeah certainly well you rarely see
it from the same pitching matchup that
gave you a 3-1 game right two and a half
hours right Verlander I mean Kershaw
Keuchel know they have that hat one so
Sean Casey of the MLB Network here so
what do you think happens this evening
wow I don't know you know because I you
know looking back at Game five it's so
unpredictable it's so unpredictable but
I think Verlander is so has been hasn't
lost since he's been with the Astros
he's been so dominant you know and I I
would I would you would think how Game
six of Astra's are gonna win in Game six
but I think it's been such a crazy world
series and so back and forth your gut
tells you there's gonna be a game seven
I just you know I just Rich Hill pitched
well last time last time out I think
that was a you know looking back at the
series him coming out after four innings
only one hit I think that kind of tax
that bullpen you know you saw that in
Game five but I think it's gonna go
seven games somehow I think Verlander is
gonna pitch well but I think somehow
this series goes seven yeah I mean we
were talking about that with Michael Kay
um because that was the same day that
the day after Rich Hill was removed from
that game right in four innings was the
same day that Joe Girardi got fired so
we had Michael on and he said that that
was right then and there the whole
problem with analytics is that rich
Hills throwing throwing so well he
strikes out seven in the first four
innings but the analytics says if he
faces a lineup a third time through yeah
and so Roberts pulls him yeah what is
your what is your take on the analytical
world and now it has totally taken over
well sometimes I think you know you have
to go with your gut to like you know I
think you can't just it can't all be
analytics like even like AJ Hinch the
other night leaving peacock in the
you know three and two thirds right and
all of a sudden looking there's there's
peacock out for the ninth well AJ Hinch
had a hunch hey listen I'm looking he
bribed them you know McCann says he
looks good he's blowing his fastball 92
93 so I think sometimes you got a you
know go with your gut but you know Dave
Roberts said this is what we thought
with a third time through our bullpen
through 28 scoreless in a row innings in
a row so they they figured they would
just do that but what's funny is Rich
Hill if you look at the analytics the
third time through the lineup and get
guys like 158 off them and he hasn't
given up a home runs you know in that
third time through so that's an analytic
I guess they didn't look at but no doubt
that them doing that the Dodgers doing
that after four new stacks it's showing
up now it's starting to show up having
to throw Brandon Morrow every day that
in every game so far and you know he
kind of gave it up in Game five yeah I
think he'll is gonna see that line at
the third time through I mean he's got
to give him some length
he's like could you see him Kenley
Jansen throwing was throwing 91 the
other night he's throwing 91 91 Morrow
was in the mid-90s which he's usually
upper 90s those guys are definitely
taxed Sean Casey here on the Rich Eisen
show ok so then who who's the guy
for the Dodgers tonight that needs to
step right in there is it Bellinger
because he's been he's been kind of wild
lights out always get hot he's getting
right yes because he's got to be some
Bollinger and like you know and I think
of it you know out here Turner you know
I think I think well the guys were
struggling and I think game 5 was huge
for the Dodgers and everyone's all the
Astros it was 13 12 in extra innings
don't forget about Taylor with a big hit
we with the big Homer and a ninth you
know Turner drove a couple balls and one
off the top of the fence Bellinger with
the three-run homer in the big triple
that lineup all of a sudden is getting
hot that's why I think I'd be shocked if
Verlander completely shuts them down in
game six
you think there's gonna be games soon I
think so well don't you want to see a
rich of course who doesn't like Game
seven I know especially since people
here in Los Angeles have been so all-in
on the Dodgers they did not see this
coming
they did not see the Astros coming they
really really did not right they thought
the Yankees were coming too right and
now here comes yeah that this is a team
that they have felt destined all year
long and plus there's a I know a bunch
of
fans moms dads who are gonna be
trick-or-treating tonight all the nights
for a game you know they might need to
go early with those kids out there early
right what's a game so what do you think
of the managerial changes Shawn which
one do you think is a great hire and the
one that left you scratching your head
the most of the five let's start with
that second one first which one left you
scratching your head firing the most
couple I mean Dusty Baker you know I
mean you know for the Nationals to win
all those games I know that I know that
that Clubhouse love bake and it's not
easy to win 90 plus games you know I
don't care what market you're in and
what kind of team you have I scratch my
head a little bit on that one Joe
Girardi leaving I think that scratch my
head a little bit on that one - I mean
it's had so much success I don't know if
him in cash from didn't hey buddy
yeah yeah so that that was definitely a
head scratcher seeing Dave Martinez
though get hired in in Washington I
think that's gonna be great was the
bench coach for Madden for all those
years and then Gabe Kapler yeah I got
hired with the Phillies yeah so very
rarely did you ever ever have a manager
that could kick your ass I know I know
Jim Leyland I was scared of Jim it was
like you know I'm like if you like cross
Jim you know I think he would he would
kick your butt time for a quick story so
I'm at one time I was you know skips
always you know he back in the day you
get crushed here's you know in
Pittsburgh it was no big deal but right
now you know they're like you gotta go
in the tunnel right so so when he went
in the tunnel they smoke as heaters you
know you didn't you didn't mess with
them because it was like your pit bull
ate his food you know I mean like don't
don't even talk to him or anything so
Gavin Floyd hits me with a cutter about
95 on our right and right my elbow boom
and I'm like oh and my whole body goes
numb so I'm sitting in the just can't
even move
here comes Leland Isaac you all right
I'm like no I'm not all right I'm numb
he said what can't stay in the game and
I'm so scared to tell him knows like
yeah I can stay in the game I'm fine so
go down to first inning hands come out
right
I can't even lift my arm like literally
and I'm playing first base I would just
were when writing the teeth so I'm like
I can't go back out there so I go to
gene LeMond like gee no I can't go out
there I can't film army said go tell
skip was like you go telescope I can't
do it so I went down there I'm like he
said you got to tell him so I go down
I'm like skip skipping he's just in his
chair
you know what his head down thinking
about the game crushing the heater I'm
like I'm like skip I'm I like him I like
him and I was like I can't feel my arm
it's numb I was I don't think I can go
he's like Oh flustered he's like a part
tell Geo to get Marcus tubes in a game
go get some ice on that never ever
bother me again when I'm smoking heaters
and you know he was the one guy was
always a little scared of you know great
friend of my love them to death my
favorite probably my favorite manager
but but he had the edge like hey he's
your dad you're always a little scared
of your dad
yeah now you're here your colleagues
with police act now and we had a
three-second that's very chair I think
one week ago today as a matter of fact
please sex the best he is great he told
a great story of when he knew he was
done that he threw one with all his
might and he thought that it was
definitely mid-90s he looked up and it
said like 87 he's like that's it right
I'm done I'm finished Sean Casey do you
recall was there a moment where you're
like okay it's now time to go um go on
the MLB Network and you know what
obviously I wasn't the fastest guy ever
right and I you know it was tough break
on that one but I can hit a little bit
and I remember it was in Boston I hit a
ball in the gap and I just like I got
like thrown out again but like it was in
the gap like hit the top offense I was
like that's a homer you know I mean so I
I didn't have the full spring comb I'm
rounding first base and Nick Markakis
crabs at bare hands it throws it in the
second come out by like 15 feet it was
it and I'd already hit one off the
monster I think and got thrown out so
the crowds like quit running
you know you're so slow Yeah right I'm
like yeah I can't even get it I could
stretch it into a double and I come in
and Terry Francona's like he's like hey
Casey I talked to her cooking is like
yeah he's like you think there's a
chance you might have polio and I said I
don't know there might be a chance but I
was like he's like cuz you just keep
getting thrown out of second base I go
you know what they're to me maybe you
know what skip maybe it's time for me
just retired
move on go off into the sunset I've
interviewed him once and everybody who
has who has come across him says that he
is the greatest of all time he is the
grace goat he's all of Famer Roger goes
definitely Hall of Fame I think and one
of the most humble guys you'll ever meet
in your life and you talk about you know
navigating the clubhouse him him and Jim
Jim Leyland I was so fortunate my last
three years in the big leagues played
for Jim for two years than Tito my last
year in Boston I mean epic you know the
guy's a legend and then the X's nose is
the best but as a communicator with
those with those guys he's so funny he's
never serious he's awesome so Shaun
Casey you say just in your gut the
Dodgers get past Verlander tonight yep
and create a game seven yes and is it is
it really a coin flip and that one or
who would you get I think it's gonna be
a coin III I think I initially said
Dodgers and 6mm obviously that's not
gonna happen no but uh you know I think
I think your guess is as good as mine
now I I think it I think there's going
to be a seven game seven I think verlan
is gonna pitch great but I think there's
going to be a moment tonight where where
it gets at the game seven Shawn come
back any time this is great rich I
appreciate ya next time you you you you
you show up here I will not be what do
you think Casey and the rest of the MLB
Network crew tonight at Dodger Stadium
or right at new knee here in Los Angeles
time with MLB network's live World
Series coverage and then at 6:00 p.m.
Eastern is MLB tonight and then after
Game six and then obviously there's a
game seven if that happens oh yeah
for more Rich Eisen show tuned -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Rich Eisen show app